what's going on reject nation I'm Greg
Al and I'm John Humphrey we're gonna
watch the trailer day for American
Horror Story season seven I've been
looking forward to this ever since I
heard the time frame in which Ryan
Murphy said this would be taking place
and and as a heads up put citizen on
another video or temporarily disabling
comments right now at least until I'm
caught up on the defenders and when Game
of Thrones is over season yeah just
because this is it's really hard because
there's so many videos that are not Game
of Thrones related we will see comments
I avoid a lot of social media now just
to avoid any potential spoilers we've
both gotten some pretty major spoilers
off unrelated it feels good to take a
break from comments but if there's
specific video requests you have go
ahead and tweet us I have two greg alba
at dad John Humphrey or post it on our
Facebook comm slash surreal rejects
today it's a patient of the day shout
out Natalie Duran Natalie beautiful
woman you I'm gonna be giving you a
shout out right after this video I'm
gonna be giving you a shot whatever does
not delete take it's on the video I've
seen American Horror Story seasons 1
through 5 have not seen six yet but you
know you don't need to watch any of the
other ones I've seen one in two and
episodes from each of the rest of the
season watch oh man you're looking
comments are disabled previous video
what's the thing education
it is now official Donald Trump is the
next president of the United States
Oh recurrence of the chloroform yes
[Music]
fills your heart with dread
I've always enjoyed children here I got
this for you
just don't tell your moms I'm not making
this indeed if you get people scared
enough the world on fire
[Music]
oh just right around the corner Wow oh
sweet I think he's saying kill me that
looks really good man
that looks really cool that looks real
I'm surprised the story's getting
political people yeah and I'm actually
surprised at least in this trailer I
don't know how much the the election
specifically is gonna figure in like
throughout every episode but I thought
they said that like we're not gonna make
put Trump in the show and this starts
off with Trump I think well it sounds
like that's the basis of the pilot to me
yeah of the timeframe when this all
takes place it sounds to me like they're
gonna be doing the examination of the
kind of people that are Pro Trump and
not approach from just gonna be very
fascinating this will be the most
opinionated American Horror Story ever
yet
yeah wine also I mean they got all that
twisty the clown stuff yeah to like
directly or into about a charity show
yeah and freak show is linked to
covenant too isn't it coming coming
yeah alien covenant characters - yeah it
can only get confusing because they have
actors like Sarah Paulsen's been in all
of them it can get confusing because you
know she plays like so many different
characters throughout all the seasons of
American Horror Story yes you're like
wait a minute I like those little
tie-ins they do in American Horror Story
and Evan Peters to me is I would want to
do a video about this for a long time
and maybe I'll wait till season 7 comes
out for this I think Evan Peters is the
next Johnny Depp like good Johnny Depp
not wife-beater sick of a king Johnny
Depp what happened Johnny yeah I'm with
you there too I mean I didn't I didn't
love tape and I'm on the record saying
he really impressed me his kid yeah well
this whole variety of roles that he gets
to demonstrate in American Horror Story
and in film as well I really think Evan
Peters is the next Johnny Depp in terms
of weird characters that he's super
commits like not afraid to be weird it's
still really good looking me yeah
I'm super-excited to see like he looked
wild did he mister character with a blue
hair a psychopath like pain experiments
it looks like he's doing with people and
the titles of American Horror Story
always explore familiar horror elements
I'm surprised that I never caught on to
haven't done a cult season yet you know
well I'm using the subject matter of you
know politics in the election that's a
great way to bring in cult yeah as an
idea because you know cults form around
all kinds of things and there are
definitely political cults and it looks
like they're gonna jump into more than
just that like these clowns like I don't
even know the nature whether these are
real-life clowns or hallucinatory clowns
or both and people hate clowns man it's
a crazy trailer for only one minute long
it's insanely like jam-packed at the
same time I get the sense that it might
feel slightly more contained granted I
haven't seen season six yet with all
these seasons I've seen so far it's
always such a huge ensemble and why I
know there will be a big ensemble here I
feel like it's focus will be a little
more contained on specific characters
because it's primarily Sarah Paulson and
Evan Peters yeah yeah it seems like
those are the two those are definitely
the two main yes stories we see here and
then they feature Alison Pill a lot yeah
I mean this is this is kind of an obtuse
trailer to me cuz I can't grab a lot of
context out of this but I am very
intrigued and there are a lot of
children yeah and I wonder if maybe
they're gonna take this because it's
such a specific jumping-off point with
the election that kind of puts you in
one specific time so I wonder if this
might be a more contains yeah I don't
think we get any glimpses of some of the
other cast in this so I wonder how like
Lena Dunham is gonna figure in I think
when Trump finally gets impeached
Reimer if he's gonna do that as American
crime story our base of subscribers is
primarily Republican so we gotta watch
what we say we do I love Trump I think
fresh from a president ever watched any
videos of us you know the we we said
that Peters aside yeah definitely yeah I
love Neil we did not have a sardar sarah
paulson moment you know when he got
elected we didn't feel strange inside
yeah and we weren't horrified and
worried and we think this year has been
going better than any year we've been
alive the best year it's in the best
year the greatest results
oh and before we wrap up this video
Natalie Duran Duran she has pledged on
our patreon and she is gorgeous she is
really pretty
when I started watching arrow if she was
talking to me a lot and I'm not hitting
on you I'm not hitting on you I'm just
here to say you're really hot I'm saying
I can tell you look at their state
totally okay for me to compliment you
because I'm probably not gonna see you
in persons technically not hitting on
somebody if you're more than a hundred
miles away that is sure it's true
because how can you hit them it's in the
water
heartily great conversationalist and we
message a little bit on patreon because
I want her to see what I can give her a
shout out to while we were how was his
message that's what I do on patreon a
message people I'm just nervous because
now I complimented her she has a really
commendable job she works with elderly
people and she's tell me a little bit
about what she does and it sounds like a
rather stressful but important job to do
so Natalie keep up with what you're
doing keep watching the channel I am
proud of you and all the hard work you
do I've got a big heart and stay pretty
because that is honestly the most
important thing you can do if everything
else fails as long as you're
good-looking you're gonna be okay just
ask this guy remember these words looks
are every subscriber the real rejects
click that notification bell - on
Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram follow
us at patreon.com slash the real rejects
a good day